non ce n'est pas encore l'heure des
résultats ni celle de découvrir qu'on
l'a ou pas le bac 2018 ne fait que
commencer
à l'entrée du lycée on cherche sa salle
et comme chaque fois chez les candidats
il y a un peu tous les états moi ça va
j'ai bien révisé pas trop de
d'inquiétude
moi c'est total gros stress la philo
c'est pas pour moi
sauf que pour tous la philo c'est
coefficient 7
alors mieux vaut ne pas se rater le
lycée pasteur est centre d'examen pour
les littéraires il accueille plus de 200
candidats de l ya ce qu'ils voient là on
attaque les épreuves écrites il ya ceux
qui se voient moins comme toutes les
épreuves facultatives ça fait déjà
quinze jours que on est vraiment dans le
bac mais c'est un processus tout au long
de l'année de préparation
tout le monde a trouvé sa salle non
c'est bon comme partout et comme chaque
fois à 8 heures pile les sujets ont été
distribués la culture nous rend elle
plus humain où peut-on renoncer à la
liberté
vaste question les futurs bacheliers ont
eu quatre heures pour disserter